ever wonder how maleficent soars through  the air  so effortlessly behind the scenes she  doesn't have her full wings yet  but jolie does have small blue triangles  where the wings end up being added in  with cgi afterwards  what about the men in blue these are  stunt people maneuvering her movements  jolie guides them where to go with her  body by leaning in different directions  a tuning fork-like rig holds her in  place she can even spin  360. the stunt work itself is risky  jolie was almost injured by sam reilly  once in a take gone wrong  the final product looks far more  flawless than the effort it takes behind  the scenes